Rob Reiner is there anything new
anything in the newly released JFK files
that surprised you well not yet because
the they haven't really released the new
JFK files they're waiting till April and
I think that the CIA is gonna do some
they're getting out there SOS and brillo
pads they're doing some scrubbing are
you on the page that it was a conspiracy
or that it was a lone gun no I I don't
believe that
oswald could have done this by himself
everything that I've studied I've been
looking at this for 50 years now and
I've read everything that's conceivable
and every bit of forensic and all of
that in my opinion there's no way in a
million years this guy could have done
it by himself okay Rob what is the aim
of your group the committee to
investigate Russia
well the main aim of it is to let people
know the gravity of the situation and
what the Russians were able to
accomplish I don't know if you saw James
clapper he's one of our advisers on the
advisory board he's head of the Director
of National Intelligence elegance and he
is not given to you know hyperbole or
anything I got but he is an if he had
any hair would be on fire but he
basically said that he's never seen
anything quite like this kind of
security breach and the fact that we
don't have a leader at the our president
who is acknowledging it is making us
very is is making us unsafe and going
forward we need to let people know how
how important this is so I think I
personally think that our democracy is
is at stake because we're being eroded
oh yeah
Jack Jacob what do you make of Trump's
efforts to overhaul the VA well he
hasn't made any effort to over hold it
you're looking at somebody who believes
that it's kind of weird to have a
parallel system of of medical care which
is very very expensive and not
particularly efficient I think if you
served in the military and you've got an
honorable discharge
here's your Medicare card you can go
anywhere you want and that's the end of
it well it's okay with you you've been
in the Army again so you get free
medical care I said if I hadn't been in
the Army I wouldn't need any damn
medical care that's right exactly
lucky you with your purple hearts in
your Medal of veterans are like an
afterthought like you talk about them
right before the election and you hear
people say like we really want to
support the veterans let bring them out
at the convention but there's not like a
really set plan for addressing things
that we know are know there won't be a
you know the the you know there is not a
constituency among veterans we have a
relatively small number of people who
have served most Americans don't know
anybody in uniform we have one half of
one percent of the American public in
uniform we've effectively outsourced the
defense of the Republic to a very small
number of young men and women who are
willing to do that so there's not a
natural constituency I'm not surprised
nothing is ever find it disturbing that
almost half of Republicans say they want
Trump to attack North Korea that do they
really have 46 percent say let's go well
they should suit up and go do it
themselves yeah
your gram what is it what is it that
causes young American men to abandon
their comfortable lives and go fight
with Isis yeah I mean we see we see this
time and time again and which is why
it's so hard to detect that a person is
really living a parallel life one side
of their brain is living a typical
American life yeah and the wife doesn't
even know often they're actually really
comfortable - yeah it's not just that
they're right it's not they're not
lacking food they're not lacking even
jobs in many cases but it's almost like
it's a hobby that grows out a hand you
know some of the people I've spoken to
some of the people I've looked into that
they have hobby they should take up
standard collecting yes it's as if it's
like a video game copy of look where
they're sitting in their basements they
are working on on being the top of this
video game but the video game is global
jihad and they don't they they don't
tell their parents they just suddenly is
that a real thing the video game you
know the global jihad is real but the
video game is all just it like the kind
of subculture that they're part of and
then they get this idea in their head
that maybe they've been bad maybe
they've the same kind of right think you
don't want a Punnett they feel guilty
yeah and that's the clash of cultures
right what they're doing that they're
atoning for that guilt or at they the
recruitment starts with saying you're a
bad guy
you drank alcohol you gambled guess what
there's a way out and it starts with
getting a suicide vest and going to
Syria that Alcoholics Anonymous that's
for sure oh yeah okay Kristina should
Diane Feinstein take her primary
challengers seriously Diane Feinstein
are senator interesting question first
off her primary challengers are going
against her for two comments that were
put in a 70 minute conversation I've
been boiled down to like six words we
should have patience with Donald Trump
and he can be a good president she went
on and on and on and gave a lot of
context which we at the LA Times have
been covering but you know look this is
a democracy anybody has an opportunity
to to run in this race and I think that
that question you could have asked the
same thing of shouldn't Hillary Clinton
have just gone unchallenged in 2008
right I mean everybody was a better
politician
we're having a contested primary which
ultimately led to Barack Obama's
president so yeah she should take him
seriously she has a ton of money she's
got institutional support we have a poll
coming out soon that I imagine she's
going to have strong support here in
California for re-election but like
anything is possible and there are not
just one challenger she's got three on
the Left challengers and probably more a
lot of small challengers so the question
will be will she debate all of them you
know I I mean she's been a fine senator
and it's not the age issue you know I'm
very anti ageist she's strong she's
still really strong well she wasn't she
said something was inartful but it's
also I think a Democratic Party needs a
new brush people know how to fight every
time both parties need that neither
party has good leadership they do you
think the Republicans are gonna go for
the jugular no they don't have any
leadership they're all it didn't all
fragment and I would say anything around
it's working with Russia is going for
the jugular that that would be you know
my view of that one but but if you if
that's what you've got to do in order to
get into office you've got big problems
in them once you're in office and you
can't get anything accomplished
you have no leadership problem they're
getting plenty accomplished having been
in government when you're when your
parties in power for eight years in the
White House it's like a thermometer
drop the energy level drops right and
meanwhile the people out Republican or
Democrat are building up I think that
what you've got here with senator
Feinstein is she's been around for so
long she is fine senator in that sense
for California but she has been around
for so long that she's just people are
looking at her and saying I think it's
time and I think that that every
politician faces that if they said
testing loti is her
that they're saying it's her times over
it's they're saying it's it's now it's
our time like we're in our 40s or 50s
then go then go oh and sign up and try
to beat her at which you know you know
if you can be very fine
I saw her the other day she was pretty
damn good against that the person from
Facebook and saying we're not going to
let you didn't get away with this yeah
it's pretty tough that get she's the one
of the toughest on gun control of any
any senator and but could I push back a
little on this idea that Trump isn't
accomplishing anything he's
accomplishing a lot of stuff we just
don't hear about it because he distracts
us with [ __ ] about the anthem and
whatever the [ __ ] the war Widow and
there's so where everybody's talking
about that for a week and meanwhile very
slowly they undo everything Obama
everyday you know they pass these a past
ability event where you people can't sue
the banks you know trying to repeal
Obamacare and sabotaging that the EPA
they're accomplishing lots of it
horrible things there was another day
terrorizing immigrants I mean that
believe me they're accomplishing
[ __ ]
and that's what we should keep our eye
on final question don't applaud I know
how you feel about this should Twitter
kick Donald Trump off I know how you
feel about it kick like it's well but
then you know this is the old thing what
he's not gonna be president please Jesus
forever so what happens when the next
president says something somebody else
doesn't like so should they kick Trump
off the platform like it's rogue
employee did 411 I don't think they
should kick anybody right here's the
thing his twitter has the ability to
move markets the ability to piss off
dictators the ability to you know yeah
it caused a lot of that's true
chaos positive or negative however you
feel about it so who has access to that
and who could send a tweet that could
make Kim jong-il do something like
batshit crazy like that's that's what's
scary to me about that the security
level of how someone could just turn off
the president what's real significant is
not what's happening now with respect to
that but what you think is going to
happen in the future we're in the middle
of the biggest revolution of
distribution of information since the
invention of the printing press yeah I
didn't want any money and we are lesson
Jen I defy anybody to roll the tape
forward and predict what's going to
happen five years ago from so this is a
big big problem insoluble okay
Thank You panel thank you audience
[Applause]